Peter, Everett,
congratulations,
you fellas have made
it into the third round
of this competition.
Now, when you came here,
we had you make signature
blades in your signature style.
That's not going to happen
at your home forges.
Instead, you'll be
making one of these--
Genghis Khan's sword.
Sweet.
Good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
Bring your A game.
I'll bring my A-plus game.
[laughs]
[rock music]
I'm back in Austin, Texas.
And I have to make
Genghis Khan's sword.
Let's get to work.
I was considering
a Damascus build,
but I think that's a risk.
You're asking for potential
delams and weak points.
So I'm thinking of a
strong mono steel here.
I'm going to go function,
function, function.
I think that it's going to
be a challenge, no matter
what, just sheer length.
You know, the longer
it is, it's harder
to keep these things straight.
You're asking for warps and
other weirdness to go on.
I'm hoping to get the
whole fuller in today
and the tang shaped out.
I'm pretty happy with
how it's going so far.
So basically, my sword
is ready to quench now.
I pull it out.
Wow, it's pretty straight.
And it's hard.
This is a huge relief.
[rock music]
So this is day 2.
It seems like day
10 or something.
It's brutal.
I'm forging along.
It's starting to
stretch out nicely.
I want to leave it a little
bit thick to avoid a big--
[whoosh]
I should be able to get
into some heat treat.
I really want to get this
done right the first time.
I don't want
something to go wrong.
I pull it out--
not bad.
Not like a pool stick.
But it's got a little
whoop-de-doo in.
But I've got a lot
of meat on the blade
to straighten that out.
[rock music]
A little tired, but nothing
some good coffee won't cure.
I got a octagonal
guard knocked out.
And I'm going to make some
epoxy and set some pins,
and then we'll start
thinking about our butt cap.
My plan is to put this butt
guard on and use the press,
just real gently, to conform
the metal over the groove,
and have it lock
into place so it's
got this physical connection.
I go to the press.
It feels like it should
just press into place.
And then it
immediately goes south.
Ah!
Crap.
I break my freaking handle.
It looks like I
popped it open there.
I notice the
handle's screwed up,
so I gotta pry it off, and clean
everything up, and re-epoxy,
re-pin everything.
Round two.
I also have to fix the butt
cap that I messed up trying
to press it into the tang.
I have to change my
game plan and attach
the butt plate by epoxy.
I do feel like I'll be able to
get a handle on the situation.
[laughs]
[rock music]
I'm trying to figure
out this handle design.
The finishing of
a weapon, I feel,
is the most time consuming.
This is tedious.
So I got this curved
tang to deal with.
So I decide to
cut the pieces up.
My idea is to have
this tang sticking out,
because I have to put
this little hole in there
for a little--
[whistles] little tassels.
Put the handle together,
doing the dry fit.
Uh-oh.
See, my angle's way off.
Hmm.
I'm going to go bend
this tang just a hair.
It's gonna be real close.
I really thought I'd
be further along, like,
pretty much done right now.
But I think I'm set up good
for tomorrow to finish.
[rock music]
It's the last day.
I have a sword.
So now, it's sharpen,
sharpen, sharpen.
I'm going for a very sharp edge.
And that's a bit of
a calculated risk.
So it will certainly help in the
cut and potentially kill test.
But if the strength
test is bashing
against bones or
something, then this
could be a detractor for me.
I believe my sword is a lot like
Genghis Khan, actually-- sharp
and really frickin' brutal.
I think there's only
one thing left to do.
We've got to give this
some sort of test.
Woo!
OK.
That was kind of cool.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your sword
and deliver some killing
blows to this ballistics dummy.
Peter, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[rock music]
[blade impacts]
[grunts]
[chuckles]
All right, Peter, first
up, your edge is sharp.
The balance feels good.
But it did take quite
a pronounced bend.
But the more important
thing is, it will kill.
I timed that perfectly.
[laughs]
All right, Doc Everett,
are you ready, sir?
Let's do some surgery.
[rock music]
Yikes.
All right, Everett,
your edge is very sharp.
It slashes nicely.
Your tip punctures easily.
Cuts on the way out.
With all these cuts, it'll kill.
[laughs]
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test.
Now, to test the strength
and overall construction
of your blades,
I'll be attacking
our armored targets over here.
Peter, you're up first.
You ready?
Let her rip, tater chip.
[rock music]
[blade impacts]
All right, Peter.
I'm gonna start
with your handle.
I find it really comfortable the
way it flares towards the tip.
It works pretty
good for my hand.
And I love what you
did with this kind
of low-layer count Damascus.
It's very dramatic.
But we've got some very
deep rolls on this edge.
There they go.
You hear it?
Those chips, that's an issue.
But all in all,
you did a good job.
All right, Everett, you ready?
I am.
OK.
[rock music]
Ah, piece of armor.
Nice.
All right, Everett,
your blade, still spot on.
What I really like is
the fact that that blade
is, at its widest point,
maybe 3/16 of an inch.
You don't need weight
and mass for strength
in a properly tempered blade.
That's really good.
You've got a section of
blade here that's not quite
as sharp as it was right there.
All in all, I think
you did a great job.
Awesome.
All right, bladesmiths,
this is the war banner slice.
To test the sharpness of your
blade, I will take your weapon
and slash across
these war banners.
Peter, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[rock music]
[blade impacts]
So where your edge
has a chip, you can see,
it catches and rips
through the banner.
Where it's not, it cuts nicely.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
All right, Everett,
it's your turn.
You ready, sir?
I think this beats the
hell out of peer review.
All right, let's find out.
[laughs]
[rock music]
[blade impacts]
OK, Everett, your
edge here does cut.
It's sharp.
It cuts in some of the areas.
On some parts of it, it ripped.
But overall, sir, it will cut.
Awesome.
All right, gentlemen, based on
what we've seen in the weapons
test, the judges have
made their final decision
about which of you is our
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Peter, your sword took the most
damage in our strength test.
You had a rolled edge,
and your blade bent.
For that reason, I have to
dismiss you from the forge.
Come on forward.
I feel a little sad.
But it's been an
awesome experience.
This loss is not
going to deter me.
It's going to just
make me stronger.
I may not be the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
But I still think
I'm a badass smith.
Well, Everett, your blade
is comfortable, well-balanced,
strong, and deadly.
And that makes you the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
And that's a title that comes
with a check for 10 grand.
Good job.
Come on forward and
shake our hands.
[laughs]
This experience was really fun.
It was really tough
in a lot of places.
And it's been a hell of a ride.
[rock music]